I wanted to get to Jeff Passan because
he's hot on a topic that we've been hot
on and that is what are we gonna do with
the netting for Major League Baseball
down the right-field in left field line
and I always maintain it takes something
unfortunately you know tragic to happen
before we act upon this with what
happened with the Astros in one of their
games with a four-year-old who was hurt
I believe a woman was hurt at a White
Sox game as recently as a week ago and
the White Sox came out and said by the
end of the summer they're going to have
protective netting up the first you know
down the first and third base line and I
just curious does baseball say this is
going to be mandatory or do we wait till
next year Jeff Passan who covers
baseball for the mothership joining us
why aren't more teams taking the
initiative like the White Sox did I have
no idea I'm really legitimately wish I
had a better answer for you there
because I would feel better about the
sport that I cover that it's not people
sitting in you know glass offices
talking with lawyers about liability and
about why they're not doing this but
rather human beings being proactive in
the protection of other human beings and
that's what this comes down to Dan that
is the entirety of this argument you
have a group of people on one side who
are complaining they're not going to get
as many foul balls and that their view
is going to be obstructed and you have
children on the other side sorry I'm
going to take the kids over the adults
who need to find a better hobby than
catching foul balls and getting
autographs is this and is this point not
to Angela Lee that's really like it
seems like such a simple argument to me
but is should this be on the individual
teams or should this just be a mandate
from the league yeah that's a great
question I think it absolutely should be
a mandate from the league I think this
was such a missed opportunity from Rob
Manfred to say what he knew was going to
be inevitable there was going to be one
team Dan that was going to start this
and that happened to be the Chicago
White Sox yesterday but there are there
are other teams out there that have been
looking into it
have been talking with architects about
what it would take to get it done with
our ballpark every team is going to have
this style of netting when it's all said
and done and I think Rob Manfred could
have come out and said we at Major
League Baseball are going to prioritize
safety and in doing so every team by the
beginning of the 2020 season needs to
have this in place and it's an easy win
for him because if you leave it up to
the teams one team is going to do it and
then the others are gonna look like
suckers if they don't yeah I agree I I
was curious about his game plan and
we're talking about the commissioner Rob
Manfred that he was quiet and you know
we're trying to track him down and you
know apparently he was too busy to come
on and answer the questions but I just
want to know you know you didn't the
commissioners say I'm gonna put in
protective netting in between the
backstop and the dugouts like what
didn't that come from the commissioner's
office yep okay if you're going to do
that then I don't know maybe I'm just
shouting into the wind here but it just
seems like it would be logical for him
to come out and say we want you to have
the greatest experience when you go to
the ballpark and that includes fan
safety we in and I think you even
mentioned it the last time Jeff if you
want to have the protective netting you
want to bring the protective netting
down during batting practice allow you
to go down there get autographs get some
baseballs or when the game goes on then
the netting goes up that's all
like this you know I I know I keep
saying this this isn't hard like there
are you know there are a lot of
difficult things when you're in the
sports industry to make the right
decision this is not one of them and and
for baseball to to have treated it like
that a you know I almost feel like it's
it's a government style decision where
you're leaving it up to the states
instead of the federal government and
each of the 30 states in this case is a
baseball team but I'm sorry this is
something that should be a federal rule
we're
Jeff Passan from the mothership covers
Major League Baseball the other item I
wanted to talk to you about Manny
Machado received a one game suspension
for contact with an umpire over balls
and strikes and then violently throwing
is bad against the backstop the umpires
were very upset about it they tweeted
about this and so what do you what do
you make of this situation with Manny
Machado situation that I'm making then
is that some people should not be
allowed to use Twitter and and like the
guys in the Major League umpires
Association or one of them because it's
just like it was every social media
mistake you can make
they were the over hash tag guy they
were the capitalizing letters that
shouldn't be capitalized guy they were
attaching the picture because they have
no brevity guy they were the like the
angry shouting from the Porsche guy it
was like it was like a bingo of social
media faux pas and they got ratioed in
record time I mean it was a beautiful
thing to be and honestly I look Manny
Machado shouldn't have thrown as bad
it's not workplace violence like let's
not conflate something that is like a
legitimate issue with the guy getting
pissed and throwing about hey like I
love the umpires because they always do
remarkably ill-advised public displays
of aggression like remember when they
wore white wristbands and solidarity
over what I don't even remember
something that needed no solidarity it
was its baby umpires and their social
media accounts live forever Jeff good to
visit with you is Ollie's keep stirring
up thank you buddy
Jeff Passan ESPN baseball insider for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]